absolutely love this series it's exactly
what we need right now in our lives and
I love the first episode because Deepa
Mehta is Canadian so and she's amazing
it's such an amazing job why do you
think this series resonates with so many
people right now it's a good question I
think I think for one thing it's it's a
hopeful series it's a it's a series
about humanity and I think people are
really looking for things that feel good
and kind of things that they can see
themselves in so I feel like I think
that might be why it's also lovely for
you to say that it's resonating with
people that's I mean that's what we were
hoping for yeah and I think the stories
are just you know the assembly said
they're just human stories very
relatable and they're about stuff that
everybody wants which is a place to live
people to love people who love them food
you know I think that's what people
hopefully connect to it yeah and all of
us have that little America story mine's
little Canada's during my parents are
first immigrants to Canada yeah and
you're from Pakistan right I would love
to hear your story but I guess Ari would
you say you're living the American Dream
living my dream for sure it really it's
been I've been very very lucky in many
many ways definitely things you know
when I first came here I had not
imagined that I would have the
opportunities that I've had
ya know definitely living the dream
you're living the dream so much so that
you're shirtless on social media showing
your 12-packs you're like Chris
Hemsworth Ward physique I mean you blew
up the internet Kamel yeah the internet
whatever range in the night you should
also answer I told her I was gonna do it
right we discussed it a lot ahead of
time and I do think it was I felt I had
have people texting me that they wanted
to sleep with my husband and have people
texting me being like are you okay with
all this because this is crazy but sort
of felt you know I put these pictures up
and it just got it just felt really
control I couldn't believe it
it really got way crazier than I
expected it to get but is it a crazy
you're a superhero and you're Asian like
I was thinking about Duane who became a
superhero now you're doing it yeah
that's that's a yeah no it's that's very
very exciting I just finished that movie
two days ago thank you
no it's a that you know again getting to
play a superhero I never thought I'd get
the opportunity living the dream many
versions what do you love about America
right now in 2020 I love that this is a
country that always wants better for
itself and I appreciate that I
appreciate I do think if you are living
if you are awake and alive and living
you are living the American dream
because you have a chance to get up and
do something better every day and if
people value that in this country and
I'm born and raised here but I think
people value that in a way that I I
still appreciate it yeah and I think
people here are very passionate you know
no matter what you believe some people
seem to really really be passionate
about it and like they I hope that
ultimately that's not a bad thing it's
not a bad thing thank you so much
congratulations
I can't wait for season 2